- [Brian] Cool, welcome to re:Invent.
We're bright and early or
early enough on a Monday.
So very glad that you all
showed up here with us
on this Monday morning, so thank you.
- [Sean] Yeah, so I'm Sean Kendall.
I am principal solution architect at AWS.
I specialize in serverless
and generative AI.
Been with AWS for just over six years,
working out of Calgary, Alberta in Canada.
And I guess, Brian,
wanna introduce yourself?
- [Brian] Yeah, so my
name's Brian Zambrano.
I've also been around for a bit.
It's gonna be about
almost seven years at AWS.
So I was a solutions architect like Sean
for many years, developer background.
And I currently work in a group
called the Generative
AI Innovation Center.
Has anyone heard about us?
Gen AI Innovation Center?
No one?
Oh my, okay.
You need to, because what we do right now
is we are building generative AI,
call 'em proof of concepts,
more like MVPs, frankly,
for customers for free.
So if you have AWS account
team and have some idea
of how gen AI could help
you and your organization,
you should definitely
talk to your account team
because that's what we do.
Again, it's a pretty awesome deal
for all you in the
audience, the customers.
But yeah, so I'm building
gen AI solutions right now
in Innovation Center.
- [Sean] Awesome, thanks.
Alright, so today, we're
gonna be talking about
accelerating building your
serverless applications
with Kiro and MCP servers.
Now, show of hands here, who
has heard of Kiro in the room?
Quite a few people.
Okay, no, that's pretty good.
Who has used Kiro?
Okay, less hands.
So yeah, we're gonna be
focusing on that technology.
Kiro is just our agentic
AI that enables you
to build a lot faster.
And then of course, we
are gonna be focusing
on serverless here today.
Another show of hands,
who's building serverless
apps here in the room today?
Cool, a a lot of show of hands.
So that's good, 'cause
we're not gonna be focusing
too much on the serverless side.
We are gonna be building serverless apps
and showing you how to build
those a little bit better
using Kiro and faster using Kiro.
But yeah, we're not gonna
be focusing too much
on those serverless patterns and whatnot.
Now, what you're gonna
get out of here today
is we're gonna go over a
developer tool overview first,
and then a target architecture
on a TicTacToe game.
That's what we're gonna be
building here in this code talk.
We've already built the front
end of the TicTacToe game,
because we figured we don't
want Kiro to sit there
building too much stuff within
this short period of time.
So we've built that, we've deployed it,
there's an open API spec
that's available on the UI,
just so that, you know, to
kind of help the backend
and Kiro figure out how to build it
a little bit better faster.
I'm gonna show you some
prompt engineering.
So what's the prompt that I'm gonna use
to actually build the backend?
So that prompt's gonna be provided to Kiro
so it can go ahead and do
all the things with AI.
And then after I show you that,
then we're gonna get into the coding.
So you're gonna see myself, I'm
gonna be using the Kiro CLI,
which I'll tell you more
about here in a bit.
And within that Kiro CLI,
you'll see how I can build
that backend and then
I'll hand it over to Brian
who's gonna use the IDE version of Kiro.
And so you can kinda see
both flavors of Kiro.
So for the developer tool overview,
the first thing we're
gonna be using here today
is Amazon Kiro.
And within Amazon Kiro, we
have the Amazon Kiro CLI.
So now this is my preference,
what I'm building.
There's no real right or wrong here,
but the Kiro CLI allows
me to open up a terminal
and type in my prompt.
I can actually just chat,
if I really want to,
but it allows me to be
a extremely hands off.
I gave it a prompt, I hit
Enter, and I just let it go.
And it doesn't have to bother me at all.
I don't have to use a UI.
That's what I prefer.
But then the other way of
doing it is the Kiro IDE.
So if you prefer a nice IDE experience,
then this is another option for you.
We're also gonna be
talking about MCP servers.
Another show of hands,
who here has heard of MCP?
Most of the group, that's really good.
Who's using MCP today?
- [Brian] Wow, okay.
Who could explain what an MCP
server is to their friends?
Ooh, I got you on that one.
Okay, we got one.
Okay, that's great, that's great.
So we're gonna get into that.
- [Sean] Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I was just
gonna say like they're five.
- What's that?
- Like they're five.
- Like they're five, exactly.
- [Sean] That's good. (laughs)
And I'm gonna be showing you
some of the serverless MCP servers
that we have within AWS Labs today.
So after this session,
if you wanna go use these on your own,
there's a full library of MCP servers.
Basically, tools you can use
to help with your development.
So the first thing we're
gonna focus on here
is the Amazon Kiro CLI.
So what you're seeing up
on the screen right now,
that's basically what it looks
like if you're using the CLI,
you'll type in kiro-cli,
and this is how it opens.
So you get this nice little graphic.
Within here, you can basically
just start typing prompts,
and it'll respond within the terminal.
The other way of using it is the Kiro IDE
and also hands over to Brian here
so we can kind of talk
through how this one works.
- [Brian] Yeah, and
before I get into this,
just a couple things we forgot to mention.
One, this should be interactive.
So as we're coding, as
we're talking about this,
feel free to raise your
hand, shout out a question,
and we will do our best to answer it.
So we have our first one, yes.
- [Audience Member] So here's
something that (indistinct),
because when I reserved this session,
it was called Building
Serverless App with Amazon Q.
- Yes.
- And MCP server.
So Kiro has replaced
Amazon Q in this session.
Is the same going to
happen to the service?
- [Brian] So that was my second point.
So that was step one is ask me questions.
Two is you segued perfectly into it.
Who here has heard about Amazon Q?
Most people, okay.
So Q as a brand is moving to Kiro now.
So what Sean's gonna be talking about,
what I'm gonna be talking about,
the CLI went from Q CLI to Kiro CLI.
They're basically from
a functional standpoint.
It's the same thing.
Anything else to add on that one?
- [Sean] Well, actually, so
there's a progression here.
So has anyone here used Code Whisperer?
Okay, a few less people, all right.
So it actually started as Code Whisperer,
which was like the agentic AI
that then turned into Amazon Q developer.
And now that has turned into Kiro.
So we just keep renaming
things, that's all it is.
Whereas you were using Q yesterday
on the CLI, for example,
you would type Q at Enter,
which I loved by the way.
Now you type Kiro CLI, which
is a little more annoying,
but it is there.
You have a follow up question?
- [Audience Member]
Yeah, I have a follow up.
Since this session is
gonna have a Kiro IDE part,
so does all the features and practices
that you are gonna show
on Kiro IDE applicable
to the Amazon Q?
For instance, extension of visual code?
- [Brian] Those are different things.
So you're asking about the VS code plugin?
- Yeah.
So they're gonna be di
they're gonna be different.
I'll try, as we get into this,
I think it should become
obvious or more obvious,
and I'll try to talk
through it a little bit.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] So I
have a question regarding
how you pay for it,
'cause Kiro, sometime ago,
it had from regular payment option,
it was separate subscription,
and now that Q has been part of the Q CLI,
I wonder whether the same.
- [Brian] So I think,
yeah, let's hold that
for after the talk.
So we wanna get into the
technical parts of this,
and then for any
questions, we'll be outside
and we can do our best to
answer things like that.
But let me just go
through this real quick.
So Sean talked about Kiro
CLI, so this is the IDE.
So this is like, you know,
if you've used things like cursor,
it's a fork of VS code.
And so it's gonna look very
similar if you're using VS code.
So a couple things here to call out.
On the left, there's a
little ghost, the Kiro icon.
And when you click on that,
other things start showing up.
So the top, there's
something called specs.
I'm not gonna talk about that today
unless we have extra time.
But if you've heard about
spectrum development,
that is something that
is from my knowledge
is unique to Kiro.
It's pretty interesting.
And then there are the section
called agent steering docs.
I will talk about that.
And then finally, the MCP server
configuration down there at the bottom.
And on the right is where
you have your interface
to talk with your agent,
your coding assistant.
And again, this is unique to Kiro,
at least as far as aware.
You can do a what's called a vibe session,
which is just what you're used to.
Chat with your agent and
tell it to do something.
And then on the right,
there's spec-driven chat,
which is a little bit different,
which we won't get into.
So let's just get in at,
this is a very high level
about what is an MCP server.
So what it stands for -
Model Context Protocol.
And so if you think
about you as developers,
you're gonna go and interact with an agent
to go and do something, right?
Like build me a React UI,
go and update my serverless
application to do this, whatever.
So you're interacting with some agent,
and the agent has, there's
a model behind the scenes,
it's gonna have some internal knowledge
based on whenever it was trained, right?
New things pop up.
There are other pieces of data
that could be really useful
for your agent to know about,
which it doesn't know about.
Or you might want to enable it
to actually perform
actions on your behalf.
And so you do that by
integrating with other systems.
So here, as an example,
you could be integrating
with a third party API,
or your own company's internal API, right?
We were talking this morning,
Sean's customer was building a POC
to actually have an agent place an order
for their customer, for their customer,
his customer's customers.
And so there are all these
things and information
and features that you
would like your agent
to be aware of and
actually have access to.
And so how do you do that?
And the answer for that
is now these MCP servers.
And so think about MCP
servers as a common interface
to backend systems to
either get new knowledge
to perform actions, but
it's a standard interface.
It's a protocol.
And so you could literally
build an MCP server
like as shown on the screen
to do these things, right?
Interact with my third party
API, go and figure out,
go and read the business logic
of my internal application,
or reach into a database
and go read information
or write information.
So you could do that.
But I think what we're
seeing over and over now
is that there are
purpose built MTP servers
that have specific
duties that do one thing
or a set of things that are
all wrapped around a given job.
So for example, there might
be a database MTP server
that is going to be running
database queries for you,
and you can see on and on how this goes.
But the overall idea here is, you know,
as you leave, think
about this as MCP servers
are a way to, actually, next slide.
So MCP servers and connections
are a way to give the models access
to new up-to-date information.
And it's something that information
that they don't know about inherently.
So that's the big thing there.
Okay, you wanna take this one, Sean?
- Sure.
- Some examples?
- [Sean] Yeah, so some
examples of MCP servers
that you might see.
And one that we're gonna
be using here today
within the actual coding session
is up-to-date AWS documentation.
So of course, the models you're using
when you are vibe coding
and you're building these
solutions through AI,
they understand AWS, they
understand the documentation,
but only up to a specific date
of when that training ended.
So now, adding in the AWS
documentation MCP server,
it's gonna be able to reference
the latest documentation.
For example, all the new features
that are coming out this week.
You'll be able to build
those as they get released
and as they get published
out onto the documentation.
So that's one of the good use
cases for these MCP servers,
and a good example of what we use today.
Now, if you're developing production apps
that are now gonna connect
through MCP servers,
up-to-date stock prices would
be another good example.
Weather data, anything to do
with any API integrations, right?
So now, you can just have an MCP server
execute those integrations
for you through AI,
and then basically any of
your company's internal API
or internal documentation as well.
So really, any types of data lookup
that you need in real time without using
the models training data is a
really good way to see that.
Now, today within the coding session,
here's some of the MCP
servers we're gonna be using.
So the first one is the
AWS serverless MCP server.
This MCP server deals with SAM integration
so it understands SAM
and understands all the
commands of how to use SAM.
And it'll actually execute those for you
within your own environment.
It can do local testing,
and it gives you serverless guidance.
So for any serverless app,
this is a really good one
to add into your coding agent.
Then we have the AWS CDK MCP server,
which is a personal preference of mine,
and that's because I like to
build everything within CDK.
I like to write all my own code in Python.
And so this will allow it
to now write my applications
within that Python code in CDK.
One of the things I also get out of this
is when you're using
the AWS CDK MCP server,
it will actually add in
a library called CDK Nag.
And within CDK Nag, it makes sure
that whatever I'm building is secure.
It'll actually fail a
build if it's not secure.
And one thing that you
might find your agent doing
is it might say, well, all serverless apps
must have WAF enabled, right?
But then it might say, "Well,
I'm not going to add WAF,
you're just building a demo."
So it'll put an exception in there
and then you can view those exceptions.
And if you really want it to have WAF,
you can remove the exception manually
and then tell the the agent, say,
"Well no, please add WAF back into it
and it'll go and add that
to make sure it's not an exception."
So I really like that
about the CDK MCP server
'cause it does make it more secure.
But I have seen a lot of people build
very insecure things using AI.
So that's one thing to
really watch out for.
It will also integrate power tools.
So if any of you're building
things with lambda today
and you're using the power tools library,
it has all knowledgeable power tools,
so it'll be able to add
that in there as well
to make your things
like your observability
a little bit better and
all the different patterns
that come with the power tools.
Then we have the AWS Core MCP Server.
I would say this is a really good one
to have pretty much all the time.
It has prompt understanding inside of it.
So if you're not the best
at prompt engineering yet,
and I would say like when I first started,
you don't really know
how to create a prompt,
you just kinda talk to the
thing, and hopefully, it's good,
and over time, I got a lot better.
Well, the prompt understanding
will take your input
and it'll turn into something
that's a little bit better
for building software on AWS.
So it is tailored towards that.
So that's what comes with
the AWS Core MCP server.
But as well, it has a router
for other MCP servers.
I don't personally use it 'cause I like
to be very specific on
the MCP servers I use,
but there's an environment
variable you can pass in
to the AWS core MCP server for a persona.
So I can say I'm a developer
persona or an architect.
And for those personas, it'll add a set
of other MCP servers with it.
So if you don't know which ones to use,
that's another good way to get started.
The AWS Documentation MCP server,
that's one I was referring to before.
It has basically access to
all up-to-date information
on the AWS services,
best practices, limits,
APIs, all that kind of stuff.
And then finally, a non-AWS MCP server
I'm gonna be using today.
And this is the MCP server fetch,
which is an anthropic MCP server.
Basically, it just gives
you the ability to reach out
to the internet and load a page.
So within our TicTacToe application
where we'll be building today,
the front end has an open
API spec attached to it
that you can actually
visualize within the UI.
And so I'm going to tell my prompt
to basically go and
pull that Open API Spec
and make a backend that matches it.
So that's how I'm gonna be using
the fetch MCP server today.
Any questions before
we go forward on here?
Yeah?
- You might cover this
in a second.
When you're using Kiro
CLI, do these things
just already have them or you
have to opt into each one?
- [Sean] Yeah, so within
actually both experiences.
So Kiro CL or the Kiro IDE
I believe comes prepackaged
with fetch, is that correct?
I think fetch is in there.
You have to enable it.
- But it's disabled, yeah.
- [Sean] It's disabled,
so you have to enable it.
- [Brian] Yeah, if you create
a brand new project in Kiro,
that there'll be one MCP
server there that's disabled,
which is fetch.
And so you can go in and you
can remove it completely,
you can enable it globally,
you can do whatever you want.
- [Audience Member] So
you're gonna have to add
all these listed, it sound great.
- [Sean] Yeah, so yeah,
everything else basically,
you have to add, and so there's a website.
I'm gonna show you what it looks like.
It's a GitHub page that we maintain
all of our MCP servers on,
which of course you can use
all the AWS ones, but you can
use any MCP from anywhere.
Like if you purchase some SaaS software,
a lot of SaaS solutions are now coming out
with their own MCP servers.
You just have to download
whatever definition they give you
and put it into the IDE.
Okay, so the target architecture
we're looking for today
is something like this, right?
And just full transparency,
we built the app.
I actually used Kiro to build the app.
And then I told it to generate a diagram,
'cause there is a diagram
MCP server as well,
which I can show you later if you want.
And this is the diagram you came up with.
So first, it built the
code, it deployed the code,
and then it built this diagram.
And so today, I mean,
like I'm not actually
gonna feed this diagram into the prompt.
I could, but I'm not going to.
I'm gonna let it kind of figure out
whatever it wants to do by itself.
If I really want to stick
to something like this,
then I would actually
give this to the agent,
and I would say, "Follow this image.
See how I want the architecture
and build this exact architecture."
And it would just give
it a little more guidance
to follow exactly what this is.
Now, the one thing that you
won't see us building today
is the left hand side of this, right?
So the cloud front with
the origin access control,
with the S3 bucket, that's
just hosting the website.
So I wanted to show that on the diagram.
But everything on the right hand side
is what we'll be building here today.
- [Brian] And just one quick shout out
to the serverless part of this.
Good luck doing this with
Kubernetes in 45 minutes, right?
Honestly.
And so, you know, kind of our
pitch here is that serverless,
you can go really fast.
Serverless with AI,
tooling, and MCP servers,
you can go really, really, really fast.
So it's crazy how fast Sean
and I were able to do this.
So we were even talking before this
about what if we finish early?
What are we gonna do next?
'Cause we can go so fast with this.
So just, again, shout out
to the serverless parts
of this talk.
- Okay, prompt engineering.
So this is the prompt
I'm gonna be feeding in
to at least the Kiro CLI piece of this.
It's probably gonna be
different from the prompt
that Brian's gonna use on the Kiro IDE.
Now, again, this is from
me working for months.
It's almost a lifetime in ages of AI
in learning prompt engineering.
So the first thing I tell
it is build and deploy
a working serverless backend
for the TicTacToe game
hosted at, and then a URL.
So this is a deployed
URL that we already have
that I'm gonna be plugging in here.
Now, you'll notice I say build and deploy.
And I actually put that in here
because I want it to build all the code
and deploy it without coming back to me,
'cause usually what I do,
and I don't know if my
wife likes this or not,
but before bed, I think of an idea.
I write a prompt, I hit
go, and then I go to bed
and it goes and builds my thing overnight.
Then I wake up with a
fully built application.
So that's why I am always
saying "build and deploy."
The next piece of this is I'm
actually guiding it to use
that fetch MCP server to view the website
and then open the API Spec
and then I give it the direct URL
with the URI to the OpenAPI Spec, right?
So I'm giving it a little
more guidance here.
I'm even guiding it to use
the specific MCP server
so it doesn't have to guess that as well.
I'm now telling it to build the code,
deploy to my default AWS account.
Now I put this in there,
because I've learned that
if I don't tell it that,
it says, "Well, I don't
know where to deploy it."
And I do have a AWS account
pre-configured on my laptop.
So I wanna make sure that it understands
that it's allowed to use that.
And if I don't put that in there,
I find it just doesn't do it.
It'll build everything, it'll
come back to me and say,
"Okay, what do you wanna do?"
So this stops it from doing that.
I also tell it to test the API,
'cause of course when
this thing's building,
I'm probably sleeping.
So I want it to make sure it deploys
and it comes back and
it runs all the tests
to make sure whatever
it did deploy is working
and it's working as expected.
On this next section that you see here,
I'm just gonna call it a few things.
Handle the CORS headers.
Now I find, with this AI stuff,
it never handles CORS headers.
It's probably the biggest issue
I always see coming back,
where it can't actually
communicate with my backend
'cause the headers were
not added correctly.
And in fact, I tested this
a few times this morning,
and even though I put this in there,
every once in a while,
it still doesn't do it.
So that is some guidance
that I do give it.
And I also always tell
it to handle taking.
So I take all of my projects
with a project name.
So you see there, I see project equals,
and then it's gonna come
up with a project name.
I'm not even gonna give it a project name.
It'll figure that out by itself.
And then auto-delete=false.
And this is just kind
of a internal AWS thing
on all of our internal
AWS accounts as employees.
We have a script that runs every night
and deletes all of our resources
if we don't take it with this value.
So I do that so everything
doesn't get deleted overnight.
And then this final paragraph,
this is something I don't
actually usually include
in a lot of my prompts.
However, I built this thing so many times.
I've identified certain places
where it could potentially fail,
and I wanna make sure it doesn't fail.
So I add these few items
in here just to make sure
that it really understands a few things
that it continuously fails on.
And so you'll find, as
you're building in the future
your applications, if
there's certain things
that the AI is just not able to do,
you'll probably come up with
some of these items yourself.
And as you're building apps,
you'll just kind of natively
put those in at the bottom of your prompt.
Any questions?
Okay.
So let's get to coding.
So let me switch over to this one here.
And of course it didn't
load the right screen,
but that's okay.
I can fix that.
Okay, so what you're seeing here,
this is the TicTacToe
game that we built, right?
So very simple, right
now, you can't really see
anything on the screen.
There's no TicTacToe board
'cause nothing's configured.
But I actually do have a
previously configured game,
a backend that I have not yet deleted.
So let me push this in here to show you
what should work, right?
So this one, if I put this URL in here,
this is the URL to the backend
deployed to API gateway,
driven by Lambda functions.
So when I add that in here,
I can register player.
And there you go, so it works.
There's no errors on here.
I can start a new game,
and then I can start playing,
and I'll let the computer win this time.
There you go.
So that's basically the
entire thing that it does.
Now that backend was built through AI.
Now, I'm gonna show you how
I built that through AI.
And let's clear this so that
when we get our new game,
it's just nice and empty in here.
Okay, so here is my,
basically, the CLI.
And the first thing I'm gonna do
is I wanna add some agents into here.
So those MCP servers, I
already have a prebuilt agent.
I'll show you kind of how I built that.
Once you install Kiro, you're
gonna find what you have
is you have your file located inside of,
so let's open this up in Kiro.
So Kiro, it's in your .kiro.
So within your home directory, .kiro,
there's a directory that'll
be placed inside of there.
And then there's an agent's subdirectory.
And then within that subdirectory,
they're gonna give you a sample JSON file.
And that's like a default agent
that you can build yourself.
I've created one here called re:Invent.
So I'm gonna open that one here,
just so you can kind
of see how I built it.
A lot of this stuff will
come out of the box.
So the schema, for example,
that'll already be there.
You're gonna wanna give
it a name of something.
So whatever you wanna call
this agent, this coding agent,
that's how you're gonna refer to it by.
So right now, whenever
I start my Kiro CLI,
I'll always say that
minus-minus agent is re:Invent.
I give it a description.
This is really just for me.
So this is basically
saying that this agent
is able to build AWS serverless backends
using best practices.
And then I give it a prompt.
And the prompt is a system prompt.
So just imagine, every time
you wanna build something,
this system prompt is
gonna be there to guide
the AI to build in a certain way.
- [Brian] Sean, maybe make
it like one font bigger.
- [Sean] One font bigger, here.
Let me blow that up there.
- Thank you.
- Is that better?
- I'll get rid of this.
- [Brian] Yeah.
- [Sean] Yeah, that's probably better.
- [Audience Member] Just one question.
- Yeah?
- So is there a repo
that you guys have in with all the config?
- [Sean] So for most of this config,
as soon as you install Kiro,
you're gonna get that template file.
So I would say just like
take that template file,
just keep copying and pasting
it for every agent you want.
I think right now, I have
about like 10 agents,
like I have one that uses
the AWS Canvas MCP Server
for like generating images
for me and stuff like that.
I split my agents like that.
So I would just say, yeah,
once you install a Kiro,
just copy that example multiple times
and then just keep making
new agents based off of that.
There is also, I don't know
this off the top of my head,
but there is a Kiro CLI command that is,
it can generate the agent for you
and then it'll generate this whole spec.
So once you're in, sorry,
once you're in Kiro CLI,
you can also run that, the
generate agent command.
And I will show you, so
there is a repo here.
So you can see here, like I
do have different MCP servers.
So I have the core MCP
server that we talked about.
I have the fetch MCP server,
the AWS Documentation MCP
server, and so far that's it.
And now, you already know that I wanna add
a few more in here based on
that list I was showing you.
So I'm gonna add those in.
There's a few other things in here.
So like there's things
like allowed tools, right?
This allowed tools list.
One thing that Kiro is gonna do
is it's always gonna come back
if it wants to run a command
and it's gonna say, "Do you
want to run this command?"
And I would say if you're doing anything
in a sensitive environment, keep that on
so that every time
something comes back to you
to make sure it's not
doing like an RM minus RF
on a directory you wanna keep.
You'll have to actually allow that.
Everything I work on is
kind of demo purposes.
So I always start Kiro
CLI with a minus-a flag,
which means just like allow
everything and never ask me.
I would just say be a
little wary on that one.
If you're doing anything
that could potentially
damage your AWS account or your machine,
you probably want that
permission placed in there.
And then there's tool settings.
So when you start adding
MCP servers and tools,
when you read the documentation
for those MCP servers,
a lot of times, it'll come back and say,
like within documentation, it'll say,
"Well, you can have timeout."
So there's a bash timeout, for example,
on execute_bash, which is a tool.
I can say you have a
timeout of 300 seconds.
So that's one thing that
I've added into mind.
So that's where you
would put it within here.
Now, I'll show you how to
add a different MCP server.
So now of course this
is more of the CLI way,
which I think is actually
similar anyways to the IDE way.
But there's a GitHub, AWS Labs GitHub.
I'm gonna show you guys
a QR code at the end
where you can link to this.
But basically, this has
all of the AWS MCP servers,
and of course there are thousands
of MCP servers out on the internet.
These are just the ones
that AWS has curated.
So in here, I'm gonna
search for serverless,
and I have this AWS serverless MCP server.
Once I come in here, I can
quickly click these buttons.
So if I wanna add it to cursor or VS code,
I can do that from here.
Now, because I'm doing it on the CLI way,
I'm simply gonna copy
the JSON from in here,
come back into my IDE,
scroll up to my MCP
server list, and paste it.
And because I use a
default configured profile,
I'm just gonna delete
this environment stuff,
'cause that's where I can
add a specific profile
or region if I need that.
And if I get rid of that,
it'll use my default one.
So the next thing I'm
gonna do is come in here.
So right now, I'm sitting
within a directory on my machine
that has nothing inside of it.
So if I show you here, all
I have is a prompt.text
and that's just so I can easily access
that prompt I showed you.
So there's nothing else in
here, and this is the directory
where I'm gonna start building everything.
So I'm gonna start with Kiro CLI.
Now, I use a command "chat,"
which means I can use additional flag.
So this is giving me the ability
to use this minus-a flag,
which says just do anything,
never ask me for permissions.
And that's because I'm eventually
gonna hand this off to Brian
so my computer can keep working
and then his can start building on the IDE
and then for the-
- Is that bigger?
- [Sean] Oh, bigger, yeah.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for that.
All right, and then minus, minus agent.
And then I type in "reinvent."
That is that name of that agent
that I created within that JSON file.
Now, as soon as I open this here,
you're gonna see it's gonna load
my different MCP servers and validate.
I did have four in there.
So the core MCP serverless
fetch and documentation.
So yeah, that is correct.
Now, within here, there are a whole bunch
of commands you can run,
so if you type slash,
you can see there's all
these different commands.
So for one, if you wanna
manage your agents,
if you do have multiple agents,
you can do the /agent command,
which then has that generation
feature inside of it.
But the other thing you can do
is just start typing your prompt, right?
So if I open up my prompt here,
which I have saved over here,
and you can see I've pre-filled
in the website address
to our TicTacToe game,
I'm simply just gonna push this in here.
And that's really it.
Now, I am using some experimental features
within the Kiro CLI.
So if you ever type /experiment,
you'll see there's about six
different features in there.
One of them is a to-do list.
And you're gonna notice,
after it starts loading,
like right now, it's actually
fetching out to the internet,
loading that website, saying,
"Now I understand the requirements."
And now I created that to-do list.
So that's actually an
experimental feature.
So if you wanna use that,
I find it's really good
'cause it gives it more of
that chain of thought process
to build an application.
And I actually personally enable
all experimental features.
There's things like checkpoints in there,
so it's kinda like almost a git commit,
but it's local to Kiro.
Anyway, so we're gonna let this build.
It's gonna go off and do
everything that it needs to do.
Now we'll switch over here to Brian
so he can show you how to
build it within the IDE.
Is there any questions
while we're just switching laptops here?
(speaking indistinctly)
Okay.
So the question, is it persistent?
So it's actually using a Git
repository behind the scenes.
That's what the tool's actually doing.
So it is persistent.
So if you were to exit out of
Kiro and then come back in,
now, whenever you come into the Kiro CLI
a second time after leaving,
you use a minus minus resume flag,
and then that resumes
back from where it ended,
and then it'll pick up
on those checkpoints.
And also, the conversations
are stored in a directory
within that .kiro in your home directory.
So your conversation history
is all stored within there.
So every time you type minus-minus resume
in a folder that you're currently in,
it loads your conversation from there.
So everything is persistent in there.
Now, I'll pass it over to Brian here.
- [Brian] Okay, so here we go.
So this is the Kiro IDE.
So real, real quick tour.
Just like VS code or any other IDE stuff,
navigations on the left here
are my files, my file system.
And then in the upper
right, click on that,
and that is our chat
interface to our agent.
And like I said, the beginning
over here on the left,
there's this Kiro icon,
and if you click on that
and is that large enough?
Can you guys see this okay?
Yeah, okay.
So there's these spec things on top,
which we will get into if we have time.
Agent Hooks, we also won't cover this,
but I can talk to that.
And then Agent Steering docs,
which I'll show you how
to create something there.
And then the MCP servers
down here on the left.
So you can see I already have
four of these that are set up.
And so if I click on this icon
that it says open MTP config,
there are two parts to this.
One is the user config.
So this is laptop-wide.
So like Sean said, the documentation,
the MCP server enabled that one globally.
I mean, there's no really no reason
to have that per project.
So you can see in here the second one,
well, the first, there's two of them.
There's Knowledge MCP and the
AWS Documentation MTP Server.
So that's under my user configuration.
So whenever I'm logged into my laptop,
those two things are gonna
be enabled all the time.
And then the Workplace Config.
And actually, I changed
directory so that one's empty.
So there's nothing.
So the things that you see on the left now
are on my laptop no matter
what project I'm working on.
So to enable, and I'll just
do it real quick, AWS MCP.
So I'll do just what Sean did.
I'll make this bigger, serverless.
That guy.
And then we're gonna copy this,
and then all I'm doing
is I'm pacing it in here.
Again, this is the
workspace-specific configuration.
So this will only be enabled
for this one workspace.
Question?
- So for the workspace,
is this gonna live within the repo?
So my team of developers, I'll get this,
or is this a per machine configuration
that they have to do for their workspace?
- [Sean] Yeah, so you
can see right in here.
So this is in a directory,
a .kiro directory in this project.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
So as long as you commit that
and as long as everyone's using Kiro.
- [Brian] Yeah.
And now here I need to put in this,
and this is just the name of my profile.
I'm gonna save that, and as I save that,
now you'll see it's spinning
over here on the left.
And assuming I got the typing correct,
that should be enabled next.
Okay, so while that's going,
I'm gonna talk about, yeah,
so that one's working now.
So I'm gonna talk real
quick about Steering Docs.
So Sean has his setup for the Kiro CLI.
So a Steering doc is something
that the agent will reference back to
whenever it's given a task.
And you can tell it to
look at these Steering docs
based on file extension.
And frankly, I don't know
all the different ways
to configure it in terms of
telling the agent when to look at it.
But I'm gonna create a
couple of Steering docs
that informs the agent how
to build this application.
So these are really tips and tricks
to help guide the agent
when it's doing some work.
And I'm gonna do that by clicking this.
This literally changed I think last week.
So this is a little bit new to me.
I'm gonna create a Steering
document from scratch,
and it says here, "It only applies
within this specific workspace."
So that's what I want.
And I'm just gonna call this AWS SAM.
And so you can see here, it says,
"Okay, I'm gonna include this always."
And there's a link which I haven't read,
but you guys should definitely read this.
But these are some rules about what to do,
again, while the agent is working.
So I'm gonna delete this stuff real quick,
and I have something on my clipboard,
which is this one.
Not that-
- See your credit card
number on there?
- That's definitely.
That's the one where you hit like star on.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Allow all.
That was the credit card.
Let me go and find it real quick, sorry.
AWS SAM, that's what I want.
We copy, whoops.
Okay.
Okay, so if you look at,
this is pretty terse.
There's not much here.
So it just says, "Hey, this is a project
built with Python 313 and AWS SAM.
Here's some instructions:
"To test the build, run this.
To deploy it, run this.
If there are any code changes,
you can run SAM sync."
So it's really sparse.
There's not a lot here.
The code here is literally,
all I did was I ran AWS SAM in it.
So I said in it, it's a
HelloWorld application.
It does nothing other
than print out HelloWorld.
But it does deploy, but that's all I did.
I mean, it took me two minutes.
So what I'm gonna do now,
and this is I think a nice
feature of the IDE is,
you'll notice there's this
refine button in the upper right.
So I'm gonna click that,
and what that's gonna do is
it's gonna ask the agent,
take this prompt here,
the steering document.
It's also gonna look at the
code that I have in the project,
and it's going to refine or
improve my steering document.
And so that's what it's going through now.
So there we go.
So now, we're done.
But if you look at it now,
it's much more verbose.
It's a little bit more thorough,
and it's more complete.
So again, I mean, I'll just
pick some random stuff.
So here, it's saying like
what to do with sync.
The project structure, so it
looked at the file system.
So it realizes the template is
the template for the SAM app.
The source directory contains
all the function code, great.
And there's some other things in here.
Oftentimes, I mean, what
I have found is that,
oftentimes, with a
small project like this,
a lot of the work involved
is telling it what not to do.
So if you don't tell
it, skip the unit test,
skip the integration test,
don't worry about that,
oftentimes, these agents will
start creating a lot of things
that you don't want or need.
So that's just one thing
that I've noticed over time.
So be aware of that.
So I created one.
So now, in the Steering
documents, we have one,
which is AWS SAM.
I'm gonna copy another one,
which is the product.
Copy.
Alright, so I'm gonna add another one.
I'm gonna call, say this product.
And it's that.
Okay, so same thing.
There's not a lot here, but
these are just some tips.
Sean mentioned CORs, right?
We saw that the agents
didn't get that, right?
So there's a specific instruction
on there to handle it.
I've got something specific
for Lambda power tools,
and I say I want you to
use Lambda power tools
but install it as a layer.
So I will hit Refine and
then answer your question.
Yeah?
- Do these feature
be a good way to prompt the
agent to not, for instance,
read environment variables
like from secret credentials,
or is it a better way
on Kiro to prevent that?
- [Brian] So the question is,
are Steering documents a good way
to have the agent not read
environment variables or not?
Yeah, I would say yes.
I mean, the Steering documents
are a way to guide the agent
to behave how you want it to behave.
So if you don't want it to do something,
that's absolutely what I would
recommend putting in here.
- [Audience Member]
And I would assume that
all these instructions,
well, they go on each request
that we make to the underlying model
and hence they consume-
- [Brian] Tokens.
- Tokens.
- Yep.
Yeah, and if you look here,
here it says inclusion always, right?
So in this case, yeah.
And you'll see.
Let me start this and then
I'll move on to the next question.
So just to bring us back,
I have got my MCP service configured,
I've got two agent steering
documents, so that's great.
I'm gonna close these, and
now I'm gonna get my prompt,
which is gonna be 'pbcopy.'
It's fair also fairly short.
So I'm gonna create a new session here.
I could create, go on
on with a new session.
But I think it's easier just to do this.
So this is not a spec-driven prompt.
This is gonna be a vibe,
which is just a regular
prompt, like what Sean's doing.
So I'm gonna paste this in here.
So I need help to implement a
serverless TicTacToe backend
that abides by the OpenAPI
Spec, which is hosted here,
build this backend for me
using the AWS SAM application
in this repository.
Make sure to keep the
implementation simple.
I do not need unit tests
or integration tests.
So that's all I'm gonna say.
So I'm gonna hit Enter,
and then I'm gonna switch over here
so we can see the files that's creating,
and then I will answer the next question.
- Yeah.
(speaking indistinctly)
- [Audience Member]
Basically what I'm trying say
is that I saw the plan option,
which maybe it's available
as part of Kiro CLI, so whatever
you can do with Kiro CLI
and the IDE, uses the same
underlying infrastructure,
whatever, so I can actually
do everything either.
- [Sean] Yeah, so the question is,
are the CLI and the IDE at parity?
The short answer to that
is right now they're not.
So there are features that
are starting to come to both.
The intent is in the future,
and I don't have a timeline for this,
but they will be at parity,
but one thing we noticed this morning
is within my experimental
features on the CLI, right?
So there was,
which feature was it that
just came to the IDE?
- [Brian] The checkpoints.
- [Sean] Checkpoints, right.
So checkpoints just came
to the IDE recently,
that's been in the CLI for a little bit,
and it is actually still
experimental in the CLI.
So they are coming to parity.
The underlying service is
the same, however, right?
Like you are using the same models,
they're using the anthropic models.
By default, they all use a
router to get to the best model
for whatever you're trying to do,
or you can actually
specify an exact model.
The models do have different
tokens that they take.
So if you're gonna use the
anthropic Claude 4.5 Sonnet,
I think that's like a 1.3 multiplier.
Don't quote me on that exactly,
but it's something like 1.3,
whereas if you use sonnet four,
it's only times multiplier, right?
So you use more tokens on the higher ones,
and of course, tokens
then cost money, right?
So when you purchase Kiro,
this is me comes back
to the other question
from before on like the pricing, right?
You can use Kiro for free, right?
You can use a builder
ID to sign up for free.
You can use an enterprise license,
and they all have different token limits.
And of course on enterprise license,
actually, I think on any license,
you can continuously buy
more tokens or more credits.
I may have that kind of
nomenclature messed up a little bit.
All this stuff is quite new. (chuckles)
But anyways, short answer is yes.
They will eventually come to parity.
Not today, but-
- So in the future,
a new feature is introduced
to the CLI first,
or do you see that in the-
- [Sean] So far, it's been kind of,
there's been no one place where it starts.
I think there's different
teams working on them.
So whoever kind of gets
to the features first
I guess release first.
Yeah, like the steering docs right now
is only within the IDE.
However, some of those
other experimental features
were only available on the
CLI up until just recently.
Question?
- Refine feature,
which may not be available on CLI maybe.
- [Brian] Yeah, and if you think so, yeah,
the comment was the
refined feature in the IDE
is really nice, 100%.
And I think it really
depends on what you prefer
in terms of your, I mean, I'm old,
I like using Vim and and a
terminal, but I like that.
I like just clicking a button.
You can do the same thing in the CLI.
I mean, 'cause at the end of the day,
all it's doing is it's giving it a prompt.
It's giving the model some information,
and saying, "Go and do this for me."
But then including it whenever
you're running a task,
there's just some niceties.
It's more of like a quality of life thing.
It just depends on what your experience
you want to look like.
- [Audience Member] So it
seems like the MCP servers
that you're using are local MCP servers.
Are there remote?
- Yep.
These are all remote, yep, yep.
Yeah, so in there,
there are different ways
to interact with an MCP server.
Most of these are using
a command called UVX,
which runs the UV tool,
which is a Python thing.
I don't know if you know that,
but the folks who make rough in UV,
UVX is just a way to exit.
It's kind of like NPX.
It's a way to run a command locally
without having to install the package.
But yeah, it's just running a command,
and then it connects to the remote system.
- [Sean] It does support
remote and local MCP servers.
So like I do a lot of MCP development
and I always run it just locally,
'cause I have the code local
and I register it locally
and then it just all stays on my laptop.
Yeah, it does support both.
So pretty much anything that's
just an MCP, it'll support.
Now, I did notice, so
about five minutes after
I think I typed my prompt
here, it finished, right?
So I'm gonna show you kind
of what it ended up doing,
and then we'll test it just to
make sure it actually works.
- [Brian] Mine finished too.
Just saying, just saying.
- [Sean] There we go.
Does yours tell you how long it took?
- No.
- Oh, I think mine does.
Okay.
(both laughing)
So you'll see here, like
it's very chatty, right?
So like here's basically all
the output it's given me,
that to-do list.
It was showing me a lot
of the code it's writing,
and I'm just gonna keep
scrolling through this here.
It did actually finish the deployment
and then it ran tests itself.
So you can see here it's actually running
git commands using curl.
So it decided that on its own.
I didn't tell it what to do with testing.
It's running its own tests
without actually writing a unit test.
I could have also told
it to write a unit test,
if I really wanted to replay
that a bunch of times.
And here, see its even testing,
make sure I get different
errors when I need them
or when I expect them
out of the application.
And then finally, let's
scroll all the way down.
There we go, my to-do list.
It shows it's completely done.
It gives me an endpoint.
You are also, I'm gonna copy that,
and then it tells me it took
5 minutes and 11 seconds.
So I don't think we're
gonna be able to get
that out of yours, but hey, that's fine.
- [Brian] Mine was five
minutes and 10 seconds.
- [Sean] Yeah, I don't know
about that, all right. (laughs)
So I'll go back to the app here.
I'm gonna configure it, and this may fail.
We'll see.
Register player.
Hey, it worked.
- There we go.
- Here we go.
I've done this a few times
this morning, by the way.
And this is the first time
it worked on the first try.
It's been giving me those corsairs
every other time for some reason.
So there we go, so I just came
up with a validation error.
And I actually liked that
it failed on something.
If it didn't, then you
probably would've thought
that I was faking it somehow.
So I'm just gonna take that error,
I'm gonna post it into my
CLI, and then literally,
I didn't even get any context here, right?
So all I'm doing is I'm just
giving it the error message.
It's gonna know that's an error message.
And you can see already it says,
"Oh, there's a validation error."
It knows the issue, it
found the issue that fast.
It's now rewriting the code,
and it looks like, yeah,
it's gonna write that code down to a file,
it's gonna deploy it,
it's using SAM build and SAM deploy.
So it did build it using AWS SAM.
And then once this is done,
it may or may not rerun these tests.
This is the one thing,
this is all deterministic,
so it does whatever it wants,
which again is why you gotta
be safe with that minus-a flag
because when it does whatever it wants,
it might do something you don't want.
And then once it is done,
we'll test it again.
In the meantime, I guess we
can answer another question.
- [Brian] I can try mine too, but yeah.
Answer a question while I switch over.
- [Audience Member] The
SAM, when you mentioned SAM,
automatically takes care
of the gateway as well,
or gateway, we have to
mention it separately.
Should be configured in the pool,
the gateway and routing it to the-
- [Sean] You mean, like API gateway or-
- Yeah, API.
- Yeah.
So it's building it in SAM, right?
So it's using the SAM specs
to build all the infrastructures code.
Then it's using the SAM
CLI to actually build
and deploy the application as well.
So it's selected-
- [Audience Member] Take
care of building the gateway?
- [Sean] Oh, yeah, it
did everything, yeah.
It built the gateway, it built
all the lambda functions.
It wrote all the code
for the lambda functions,
and it deployed it.
It did the whole thing, right?
And usually, I would guide it to you CDK.
I didn't wanna do that this time,
'cause usually with CDK, it
takes a little bit longer.
There's just a lot more
code that it'll write,
but, oh look, yours failed too.
- [Brian] Mine failed too.
This worked in five minutes
yesterday, honestly.
- [Sean] Well, here, I'm
gonna switch back and see if,
okay, you do your error thing.
So see it might not always be single shot.
A lot of times, I can do
things in a single shot,
but not 100% of the time.
So there we go, I'm back on mine here.
It fixed the error.
It gave me the same endpoint name.
So I'm just gonna-
- [Audience Member] I
noticed one thing though.
- Yeah?
- I see a lot
where it's tracking a percentage.
So I see 22, now it's at 23.
What is that percentage?
- [Sean] That is my context window.
So that's another experimental feature.
So the question was,
there's a percentage
being tracked on the CLI.
That is my context window.
- [Audience Member] Is
it managing that window?
So as it increases above the threshold,
is that something that's gonna-
- [Sean] It will, yeah.
So as the context window reaches 100,
it will auto compact it and then I can-
- [Audience Member] Summarization or it's-
- [Brian] Yeah, it summarizes it.
- [Sean] Yeah, and so the
problem with summarization
is sometimes I lose some of
the context I wanna give.
So I do notice that if
I'm doing a lot of coding
and it summarizes, I do have to go back
and give it a little more information
that it may have lost, right?
Okay, let's just quickly
test this and see if-
- [Brian] Yes, mine was CORs,
even though I was very clear,
"Hey, this is how you
should handle a CORs."
It was a CORs issue.
- Was it?
- Yep.
- [Sean] Oh, there we go, so it's working.
Is it that smart?
No, it's not that smart.
So right now, it's pretty
much just, I think,
randomly placing.
Yeah, it's not that smart.
So I would now probably go back and say,
"Okay, I keep winning the game.
You're not placing your
turns where they should be.
Improve your algorithm."
That would be almost my next step here.
In fact, here, let me
just quickly do that.
"Improve the computer.
It's impossible for me to win."
There was a question over here.
- [Audience Member] Does it store
the infrastructure code somewhere?
- [Sean] Yeah, so the
question is does it store
the infrastructures code somewhere?
The answer to that is I hope so.
So I don't think I actually
told it to do that.
No, yeah, it did.
Well, let's see, did it
write everything in here?
There's just the SAM stuff template.
Oh yeah, 'cause it's using
SAM just a template.yaml.
So in here, you're gonna see
I have my DynamoDB table,
I have my serverless function.
So that's gonna be a Lambda function.
So yeah, everything in here
is infrastructure as code.
Now, again, like usually with
the apps I like to build,
I'll tell it to you CDK, then
it'll do a whole CDK and knit,
and it'll write all the
Python files and all that.
It just takes a bit longer for that,
but that is all in there.
Does yours work now?
- It's deploying right now.
- Okay, his is deploying.
- [Brian] Yep.
- [Audience Member] For your steering,
like one of the things that
I've seen practiced work
really good is having
some more generic snippets
that go along with the architecture.
Are you guys seeing the same
for your steering files,
or is it really just kind
of giving the high level
of just like directory structure
where the button and kind of get that way?
- [Sean] And are you saying that like
you like to give it code snippets of-
- [Audience Member] Yeah, right.
Like maybe not so much
from the serverless angle,
but like, here's how we write fast API,
the documentation that goes along with it.
Here's an example of-
- Okay.
- And like
if it needs to drill into
it more, then giving it
the link to the additional documents
so it can then go to that.
Are you guys seeing like-
- Yeah, so the question is,
within the steering docs,
do you give it a little bit more context?
Maybe it's code examples
or links to a website
that has better code examples.
Maybe a GitHub repository,
something like that.
That is something I do
with more complex projects.
So I write a lot of code to build myself
Agent COR Services.
Does everyone know what Agent COR is?
Who knows what Agent COR is?
Not that many hands.
Okay, Agent COR very
quickly is a new AWS service
that was released months ago,
and it is a service you can use to build
and host your agents.
Well, the problem with
it is there's not a lot
of documentation today
within these models.
They don't really understand it.
So a lot of times, I will
create some steering docs
and you can actually add
steering docs within the CLI.
You put them in as Read Me
files within your project,
or you can put them
within the agent config.
But yeah, a lot of times, I
will put code examples in there,
'cause I know it doesn't
know about this service yet.
It's too new, right?
I almost have to wait for
like the next set of models
to come out so it
understands it a bit more.
There's even no great
MCP service for it today.
So I do sometimes give it
some code examples like here.
This is how you do this,
so you can continue doing
all the stuff that you know how to do.
And then I'll give a little
bit of guidance with that.
And I usually only do
that after I find out
that the agent cannot build something.
So I always let it try the first time.
- [Audience Member] You added four MCPs.
Is it like necessary that
all four (indistinct),
only COR is necessary and
remaining are optional?
- [Sean] Yeah, so the question is,
I added four MCP servers.
Do I need all of those
or are they all optional?
I mean, really, all MCP
servers are optional, right?
But if you're building something
and you need reference to, let's say,
if you were building this in CDK-
Yeah, so for this
example, like the CDK one,
I probably could have removed.
In fact, I don't even know
if I included it, actually.
I know I had it in my slide,
but I don't know if I
actually included that
because I'm not building CDK.
But if I was gonna now build this in CDK,
I would add that back in to
make sure it can do that.
So be very prescriptive over
the MCP servers you're using.
Every MCP server you
add with all the tools
that come with that MCP server,
it does add tokens to your context.
So it becomes a little
more expensive to build.
And the more MCP servers you have,
the dumber it gets, right?
Because it has too many things to look at
and too many things to decide.
So curate it for kind of what you need.
Yeah, question over here.
- [Audience Member] This
is a specific to Kiro IDE.
You showed early JSON
definition of an agent.
Is there a way in the Kiro IDE,
if I'm working on a project to select,
like I want to use this
agent, and therefore,
I configure all the MCP servers
that I will need for that use case?
- [Brian] So your question is,
so these things over here
were the MCP configs.
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
but that's a configuration
of the IDE that can be done for the user
and for the workspace.
Now.
- Yep.
- [Audience Member] Is
there a way that we can have
something outside, like the
agent file that you show early,
where when I can have, for instance,
an agent for Python applications,
an agent for Node.js application,
and whenever I work on a Node.js project,
I can somehow use that
agent instead of having to-
- [Brian] I see, adding
it one by one, yeah.
So your question is, yeah, is there a way
to have specific MCP servers
using specific situations,
like a frontend application,
a Python backend application?
I don't know of a way of doing that
like for your entire system,
where it's really specific
like that for the MCP servers.
The resolution that I know about here
is either it's for your user
or it's for a workspace.
Those are the two that I know about.
- [Audience Member] But
since I think the CLI
has a special command
agent that you can use
to manage all the agents
that you have created,
I was wondering if something like that
also exists for the IDE.
- [Brian] Yeah, I'm not aware
of anything like that, yep.
- [Sean] Maybe one day if
it's not there already,
'cause I'm not aware either.
- Yeah.
- Alright, coming up
to the last minute here,
these are the QR codes
to get to all that documentation
I was talking about.
So you have the Kiro CLI, the Kiro IDE,
and that MCP server repository.
One other thing I will
say is that I just tested
the change I made, and
now I'm not able to win
my TicTacToe game.
So it did fix the algorithm.
- [Brian] And mine worked too.
It was something, silly but yeah.
And mine is really dumb.
Like I can beat it.
I did this one time,
and it used what's called
the MinMax algorithm,
and it was unbeatable.
So you just, again, non-deterministic,
you get different things
depending on the day.
- [Sean] Yeah, one last quick question.
- [Audience Member] If you have time show
about the diagram MCP
server, can you the link it?
- [Brian] Diagram MCP server?
- [Sean] Well, so if you
go to that link of the MCP,
I won't be able to show
it because it does,
it probably takes a few minutes here.
But what I would do is go to that site.
There is a diagram MCP server on there.
It's just the same JSON definition.
You would put that in, and then
you literally just tell it,
"Generated diagram,"
and it'll generate an AWS nice
format of diagram for you.
- [Brian] And then last reminder,
please fill out the session survey.
It really, really, really helps us
if you like this or even if you think
something could be better,
please give us feedback.
We really appreciate it.
- Thanks a lot.
- All right, thanks, everyone.
Have a good re:Invent.